plus
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue ce soir on attend
notamment sur des vos points de vue sur
les mesures à prendre pour enrayer la
propagation du corps un avis russe du
fameux variant angles est peut-être du
variant sud africain alors on en débat
ce soir avec sophie de menthon bonsoir
ça vous est impeccable vous étiez en
train d'en cordes chercher à vos
affaires dans votre sac et là on voit
plus rien c'est formidable c'est grand
comme sont très doués les grands
professionnels et vous en particulier
bonne année là non il faut pas vous
souhaitez les meilleurs voeux en tout
cas je le souhaite meilleur que 2020
annus horribilis
c'est le titre de cet opus qui rassemble
vos chroniques de l'an dernier très
intéressant de les re lire et de relire
notamment certaines que vous avez
écrites dans le qui sont publiés dans le
figaro
mais pas seulement à lire aussi les
écrits hautement passible d'intelligence
eux aussi avec les faits et avec l'info
vous avez le choix le dernier livre
mélenchon la chute c'est aux éditions du
rocher
l'article dans marianne sur le parti
socialiste allait certaine espérance que
adrien m'a toujours nourrie
c'est intéressant de les dire en tous
les cas et le dernier dossier de l'hebdo
sur le cabinet mckinsey qui vraiment là
on prend
on prend son grade pour son grade qui
est comme mckinsey le premier cabinet
centre ont beaucoup dans l'actu aussi il
ya l'opposition de bercy un rachat de
carrefour par le canadien à couche tard
alors est-ce une question de
souveraineté alimentaire selon bruno le
maire ou bien est-ce que dire ça c'est
complètement du délire c'est ce que dit
notre confrère de stéphane soumier sur
twitter avec qui êtes vous d'accord avec
qui êtes vous contre qui être vous dans
ce débat et bien vous allez nous le dire
en tous les cas ce soir on en débat mais
d'abord à peine en place déjà saturé le
site sante.fr qui était censé donner les
centres de vaccination disponibles
j'étais sûr que j'allais de mettre de
bonne humeur ce film en temps en vous
révélant cette information mais enfin
vous avez dû sans doute l'expérimenté si
vous avez essayé de vous connecter comme
un certain nombre de journalistes du
figaro qui raconte sur twitter les
difficultés ou de l'impossibilité qu'ils
ont rencontré aujourd'hui en tous les
cas toutes les personnes âgées de plus
de 75 ans qui ont désormais droit à la
vaccination dans l'actualité également
ses 25 départements qui sont donc soumis
au couvre-feu avancé alors ça c'est pas
l'actualité d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'actualité du week-end dernier la
question ce soir c est ce que cette
mesure va être étendu à l'ensemble du
territoire français dans un jacobinisme
cher à adrien matua là vraiment on met
l'ambiance ce soir sur le plateau
en tous les cas on vous pose la question
sur twitter et avant de débattre avant
que vous votiez pour l'instant c'est
davantage au nom je vous propose
d'écouter les points de vue opposés de
stanislas guérini à la république en
marche et de jordan barre de la vice
président du rassemblement national
couvre-feu à 18 heures il a un intérêt c
qui permet de s'attaquer à un virus qui
est un virus social le virus il se
déplace avec nous il ya à peu près un
tiers des contaminations qui sont dans
le cercle amical dans le cercle familial
l'intérêt du couvre-feu à 18 heures
c'est de contrer l'effet apéro si je
puis dire
et donc on verra la semaine prochaine
avec un peu
de recul l'effet du couvre-feu à 18
heures mais il est certain que quand on
un pacte l'effet social on impact la
progression du virus mais c'est
particulièrement utile avec ce nouveau
variant vous êtes
cette mesure serait en tout cas
s'agissant d'un couvre-feu à 18h
injustifiée et m'apparaîtrait
complètement absurde
on a mis en place un couvre-feu à 18
heures dans une quinzaine de
départements français aujourd'hui le
taux d'incidence n'a absolument pas
bougé et n'a absolument pas changé
autrement dit cette mesure est
inefficace et je vais vous dire allez
même contre-productif petit lino sophie
vous parler pendant les sonore vous ne
l'écoutez pas donc je ne sais pas sur
quoi je vais vous faire vous allez
réagir
je vais réagir bien sûr sur le
couvre-feu 18 heures lorsqu'ils
n'étaient pas d'accord alors va
effectivement on peut alors on peut
donner la parole aux internautes que je
salue ceux notamment qui nous ont
rejoints sur sur youtube youtube
lord nelson angel clément je cite le
président pompidou nous dit lord nelson
arrêtez d'emmerder les français il
faudrait que cette recommandation soit
apprise par coeur par macron castex et
veyran et mon petit doigt me dit que
c'est le point de vue de sophie alors
non je n'aime pas je trouve que poppy
d'eau est formidable il faut arrêter
d'emmerder les français mais franchement
pompidou il aurait eu une pandémie comme
ça je sais pas comment il serait
comporté il faut je moi j'ai une réagit
on peut avoir le débat mais
effectivement sur la grippe de hong kong
en 1969 qui a été une grande pandémie
mais c'est un autre débat
alors est ce que vous êtes favorable ou
pas au couvre feu étendu à tout le
territoire 18 heures moi je suis
favorable au fait que effectivement on
guette au surveille le virus comme le
lait sur le feu ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire je pense qu'il ya une absurdité
cette pensée que tous les français chose
du 38 ou du 39 du 40 et de faire la même
chose pour tout le monde parce que c'est
absurde en lozère on n'a pas besoin de
rentrer chez soi 18h bon et c'est aussi
la faute des français qui veulent
absolument un égalitarisme pour tous y
compris pour les virus on peut pas donc
c'est pas mal a ensuite de sage que je
déteste ces les fautes de bon sens et
très honnêtement j'ai questionné tout le
monde veut dire que
là vous sortez vous avez un couvre-feu à
18h d'abord on va être obligé si je peux
dire les quelques salariés qui nous
reste dans les entreprises de les faire
partir à 16 heures quand même donc ça va
être un vrai problème si on leur donne
des autorisations
alors ça je ne sais pas justement voilà
encore une fois alors les exceptions les
fausses autorisations les laisser passer
on se fait soi même tu peux me faire
aller s'est passé c'est insupportable
donc alors si on fait des exceptions
partout moi je veux bien mais je ne
crois pas je sais qu'on veut limiter la
circulation du virus dont on veut éviter
les concentrations
j'ai peur que sur une ville par exemple
comme paris on va se précipiter et on va
condenser le trafic des gens au même
moment
donc ça ne paraît pas intelligent du
tout mais c'est pas pour le principe que
je dis que je suis pas d'accord parce
que il faut faire le maximum de choses
efficace je pense que ça ne l'est pas
votre point de vue adrien donc si je
reprends ce que vient de nous dire
sophie pour résumer
couvre-feu plutôt sophie plutôt
favorable un couvre-feu de différencier
et si on étend à tous c'est que c'est
quand même la faute des français
non j'ai pas tout à fait dit ça mais
c'est parfois alors pardon j'ai
l'exemple et j'ai extrapoler la vraie
scène sophie mais je ne suis pas trompé
voilà alors je suis d'accord sur un
couvre-feu différenciée selon les
territoires
parce que vincent je vous ai vu
caricature et le jacobinisme c'est pas
du tout le jacobinisme ne consisterait
pas à imposer la même chose à tous les
terrifier pas la caricature et giacobbi
j'ai rendu hommage à votre fibre jacoby
justement alors je vais essayer de vous
doit transmettre à peut-être pas rendu
hommage en tous les cas je ne m'arrêtais
celui-ci devrait transmettre que
consiste en quoi consiste le jacobine un
jacobinisme intelligent sur cette
question c'est à dire que l'état choisit
en se basant sur les informations qui
remontent de chaque département ou du
shaq de chaque entité où il ya besoin de
faire un couvre-feu à 18 heures l'anti
jacobinisme dans ce cas-là consisterait
à laisser les collectivités locales
décider au cas par cas avec tout le lot
de démagogie que cela peut comporter
donc à mon avis moi je suis pour pour
que finalement l'état en se basant sur
les informations qu'il a dans chaque
territoire décide
est ce qu'il est nécessaire de faire un
couvre-feu est ce que ces bases
nécessaires
je voudrais quand même réagir sur
l'extrait que qu'on a passé de stanislas
guérini à mon avis il ya un petit peu le
problème de communication qui se pose là
parce que la décision de faire un
couvre-feu bon qui sommes-nous pour
véritablement la contester tous les pays
d'europe le font a priori ça ne va pas
être totalement absurde puisque tout le
monde le fait ceci dit cette année face
guérini directement il
il se rend coupable de
de ce que fait le gouvernement depuis
plusieurs semaines ça veut dire qu'ils
infantilise les français il parle de
l'effet apéro voit la manière de de
laisser entendre que les français sont
un peuple totalement irresponsable qui
fait n'importe quoi et que c'est à cause
des français que le virus se transmet
c'est aussi une manière de un petit peu
mettre au second plan
tous les errements gouvernementaux sur
sur ce problème et deuxième grand défaut
de sa communication c'est qu'ils
utilisent le werder intacte et ça ça n'a
aucun rapport avec le co vide mais j'ai
quand même du mal à part d'un mur vous
êtes au figaro donc nous sommes d'abord
esthétique
sophie sur ce que il ya deux choses que
dit adrien sais que c'est pas une mesure
du couvre feu s'est pas complètement
absurde si parce que tout le monde le
fait est ce que ça vous paraît légitime
comme comme comme justification et et
ensuite sur le sujet ce jacobinisme
différencier ou en tous les cas le fait
de dire si c'était les collectivités
locales qui prenait cette décision ce
serait ça pourrait s'ouvrir à toutes les
démagogies parce que vous êtes d'accord
d'abord le premier point tout le monde
le fait danser c'est pas mal c'est une
affirmation que je n'aurais jamais pour
autre chose mais en l'occurrence
oui je crois que tous les pays sont en
train de tâtonner et d'essayer sa mère
affolée par le confinement qui est en
train de se répandre en europe
donc parce que moi ce que je voudrais
c'est qu'on évite le confinement à tout
prix alors la question est est ce que ce
serait de la démagogie est ce que
certaines régions de prépa le couvre-feu
de stars moi j'ai plutôt confiance quand
même dans les collectivités locales
mais là encore on a il faut avoir
confiance en personne sauf dans un
espèce de comité où il ya certains
ministres des médecins qui disent le
contraire deux jours après et là on suit
donc jeu
vous avez dit que je prenais les
français pour des irresponsables ce
n'est pas vrai cela dit honnêtement
laisser leur passion commune où ils
n'ont pas su aller guy la taille c'est
vrai mais il ya aussi autre chose c'est
vrai qu on les infantilise adrian mais
vous avez vu quand même dans paris les
bars à cette heure où tout le monde
quand même trop impôts je pense pas que
les sept ans elle a dit c'est pas là
dessus que je pense pas que les enfants
les infantiliser les dissuadera de nom
ils trouveront déroger aux règles ils
trouveront un moyen donc voilà l'état a
décidé qu'il était aussi beaucoup plus
responsable que les régions je suis pas
d'accord peut-être une réaction à ce que
disent nos internautes
les gens sont le vent s'agglutiner dans
les transports en commun puis dans les
magasins pour faire leurs courses avant
de rentrer chez eux c'est stupide alors
ça c'est dans l'éventualité d'une
extension du coup au feu à 18 heures ça
vous paraît une objection et nabeul
c'est possible mais nous sommes un pays
affaibli le gouvernement en profite le
jour au gouvernement au peuple va
vraiment ça tu fais ça va exploser bon
ça c'est la prédiction de clément
propose qu'on revienne un peu après sur
ce livre le capital ou alors je vous ai
plus entendu dire vive le capital mais
mais on aura tout entendu cette voix et
donc nicole s'indigne sur sur le fait
que si le couvre-feu était attendu à 18
heures c'est le peu de vie sociale qui
reste qui devient interdite c'est pour
ça qu'ils le font est exercée lorsque
c'est pour ça que c'est comme ça que le
virus se transmette parce que ça pose
pas un problème
abbassi sa première page un peu plus
mois d'un problème majeur pour tout le
monde tout ceux qui nous écoutent
c'est vraiment stressant c'est vraiment
déprimant n'en voit pas la fin
les vaccins qui devraient nous remonter
le moral de nous remontent pas du tout
le moral
vous avez fait allusion tout à l'heure
j'ai testé tous les numéros aujourd'hui
vous raccroche au nez il ya même pas de
disque lorsque vous appelez
c'est c'est vraiment embêtant toute
l'europe risque de manquer de l'acsa et
on nous assomme tout en une scène toute
la journée qu' il ya un virus bien plus
contagieux qui arrive et c'est pas
impossible du tout donc il ya assommé
d'angoise moi je pense que les gens
psychiquement ont absolument besoin de
soupape
il n'y a pas que la santé elle est aussi
psychique et je pense que à trop tirer
sur la corde on va créer une pénurie
économique et une pénurie psychologique
qui risque d'être plus grave que le
virus surtout sur ce sujet je trouve
qu'il ya là quelque chose dont on
devrait parler c'est la fracture
générationnelle qui fils met en place
parce que la pâle beaucoup alors si on a
fait plusieurs débats sur la question
mais encore une fois il faut aguerrir se
garder d'avoir un jugement définitif sur
les mesures du gouvernement parce qu'on
voit bien on voit très bien qu'il n'ya
pas de bonne solution et qu'il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de solution idéale
c'est définition de la politique bien
sûr mais le cas échéant encore plus que
l'autre sujet mais force est de
constater voilà encore une fois sans
attente ont forcément accusateurs que
pour protéger l'immense majorité des
victimes ducobu qui ont plus de 65 ans
les jeunes générations sont complètement
sacrifiés c'est à dire que ceux qui
rendent ce marché du travail c'est la
catastrophe
il n'y a pas d'embauché ceux qui sont
étudiants les universités sont fermées
il ya deux étudiants qui viennent de se
suicider dans la galère semaine et je
pense que tous les étudiants qui
travaillent chez eux sont en situation
de solitude que n'ont pas les autres et
j'ai une demande à faire nous les
entreprises devant ces jeunes désespérés
qu'ils sont chez eux
on est prêt à accueillir plein
stagiaires même si on en a pas beaucoup
besoin c'est pas grand chose on veut les
accueillir dans les entreprises ils
n'ont pas de convention de stage on leur
en donne pas je fais un appel aux
universités à toutes les écoles fait des
conventions de stage il vaut mieux si
qui fasse un stage quitte alors on leur
laisse du temps mais il faut que is et
anne accueille un espoir et ça c'est
fondamental on peut même plus avoir de
stage il ya quand même un chiffre qui
est effrayant il ya 29 % de dépression
chez les 18 24 ans un jeune sur trois
jeux
est ce qu'il n'ya pas quelque chose qui
vous a frappé c'est qu'on a peu beaucoup
pas entendu les syndicats étudiants sur
la question en tous les cas très
tardivement on commence à les entendre
ils commencent à les entendre ils ça
fait quand même six mois je pense qu'ils
avaient un effet de sidération au début
qui fait qu'on n'a pas trop osé paraître
pour responsables en contestant les
mesures
la société vous voyez que la ministre
vidal de l'enseignement supérieur est
quand même très contesté par les par les
syndicats étudiants un effet de
sidération bien un effet de du fait que
les thématiques était ailleurs et que
aller protester contre le fait que les
étudiants puissent pas travailler c'est
pas trés vendable comme de simples
étudiants généralement c'est un peu
l'inversé quand pour lesquels on
manifeste non mais il travailla les
étudiants les malheureux ils sont tous
seuls devant leur écran il aurait par
ici un de ces jours ci c'est pour ça je
me dis que les grands syndicats
étudiants l'unef la fage ont pas été
quand même sourire est en procès sur
huit est très risqué trévise la semaine
de manifester pour aller à l'université
alors que l'heure était à la prudence
généralisée et au fait de préserver les
plus anciens c'était quelque chose est
pas préservée les plus anciennes à
écouter je vais être aux règlements
politiquement incorrect comment est-ce
qu'on vaccine tous les ehpad en premier
c'est complètement fou moi j'ai
énormément de respect on a tous une mère
qu'on adore ou une grand mère dans un
ehpad
je suis désolé à 85 ou 90 ans elle pense
que les vaccins contre la grippe et on
essaie de etc
non par contre ce qui est scandaleux
c'est pas le sujet par contre j'aurai
l'école non le sujet c'est d'obliger le
personnel soignant à être vaccinés
figurez vous qu'on on vaccine des
centenaires et que vous entendez là la
jeune femme qui travaille dans une
époque vidéo ben non moi je veux pas me
vacciner parce que j'ai pas confiance et
qui ne sont pas vaccinés
il ya un moment cantonné personnel
soignant c'est obligatoire on est
vacciné et ensuite puisqu'on arrive dans
les hôpitaux est soignée tout le monde
pourquoi est ce que les personnes qui
vont visiter ces personnes âgées ne sont
pas avec tout l'équipement qu'il faut ce
qui est le cas actuellement quand on va
à l'hôpital dans les hôpitaux dans les
ehpad en tous les cas on est obligé
d'être max et
mais masquée pardon non vaccinés il ya
une autre question sur laquelle je
voudrais vous faire réagir dans marianne
vous en prenez au recours au cabinet
mckinsey donc et cabinet de consultants
que vous soyez content par conviction et
ligne éditoriale je comprends mais si ça
marche
finalement le recours à ces cabinets de
consultants alors si ça marche ça pose
la question de pourquoi on a une
fonction publique en fait le alors je
peux pas me faire des amis sur ce plan
c'est la réponse et qu'elle est
complètement inefficace
je m'y attendais mais je pense que
honnêtement on a quand même sous la main
en france un certain nombre de grands
cadres qui sont censés je dis bien censé
disposer des compétences nécessaires
pour la conduite d'un état et que ce
n'est pas en appliquant les recettes du
privé comme le font c'est pas digne de
vous ça ah ben je maintiens pas je ne
trouve pas que appliquer les recettes du
privé soit digne oui mais ce résultat
mais ça donne pas forcément des bons
résultats en fait c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de pays qui le
font et aucune 20 j'aimerais qu'on me
mette sous les yeux les études qui
montrent que tous les gouvernements
devraient faire appel à des cabinets en
ce cas là pour décider de tout on ferait
appel à des cabinets sophie au moins ok
les boîtes de consultant à grosses
gouttes de consultants sont du benchmark
ils le font bien donc la comparaison il
donne des indications sur comment on
fait la vaccination on l'aimé les
meilleurs pays où on a les meilleures
stratégies de vaccination et c'est très
précis c'est la coordination
d'administration l'organisation dans les
territoires en quoi je sais pas ma came
price water house ou de nous sans plus
efficace que l'armée ou les préfets je
vous avez tout à fait raison à deux
exceptions près premièrement on ne se
réforme pas soi même quand il faudrait
supprimer des structures empilés qui
empêche le management ou quand vous avez
ça une commission a consulté où personne
ne prend des décisions etc
c'est ce que j'appelle du management ne
s'est pas les recettes du privé c'est
les dramatiques recettes de
l'administration donc je crois que c'est
dommage mais en même temps je jette pas
la pierre aux ne se réforme pas soi même
c'est très difficile même dans nos
entreprises on n'y arrive pas
quelquefois dans une grande boîte ont
fait appel à l'extérieur parce qu'on n'y
arrive pas donc il faut savoir aussi que
tout en cause s'est attaqué à sa selle
fait je connais ces grands groupes
ça fait dix ans qu'ils bossent avec
l'administration donc je fais le devoir
de faire répondre comme phénomène
apparemment quand même il ya un problème
adrien au ministère de la santé tout le
monde s'en plaint
l'administration de la santé en france
tout le monde s'en plaint donc est-ce
que c'est pas aussi la cause qui conduit
à ce à ce recours à des organismes
extérieurs personnes vous personne ne
vous dirais que l'administration de la
santé en france marche de manière
optimale après on peut avoir un débat
sur les causes et les manières de régler
ce problème moi je constate quand même
pour revenir au débat précédent c'est
que l'hôpital public à de graves
difficultés
depuis qu'on a importé les méthodes du
privé pas parce que les méthodes du
privé serait intrinsèquement mauvaise
mais parce qu'elles sont à mon avis
inadapté à des missions de service
public un service public n'a pas les
mêmes missions qu'une entreprise privée
c'est ça le réponse nous avons plus que
n'importe quel pays au monde plus
d'administratif dans nos hôpitaux que de
soignants premier pointe ça c'est vrai
bon ça c'est terrible
et donc quand vous parlez de méthodes du
privé jeu entièrement d'accord à ne put
aller pas fait pour être rentable à tout
prix et ch est tout à fait d'accord
simplement il est fait quand même pour
être manager ma belle-fille et ph qui me
dit je peux pas rentrer praticiens
hospitaliers wii et qui me dit je peux
pas récompensé je veux pas choisir mes
stagiaires je peux pas engueulé la tan
qui arrive pas à temps jeune héros
pouvoir je réclame un médicament avec la
clé de l'armoire aux médicaments le
samedi matin pascal personne pour donner
le constat dur et là et donc je ne jette
pas la pierre du tout et malheureusement
c'est une espèce de
c'est une analyse qui est à la fois vrai
et faux
non il s'agit pas de mettre les méthodes
du privé par contre en terme de
management
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut trois
personnes pour remplir un papier
pourquoi est ce que quand on revient à
l'accueil alors qu'on a quitté l'hôpital
la veille
on vous fera remplir un dossier complet
alors que votre chambre et même pas
encore occupés les cas sont hallucinants
donc on procède du même travers français
eux sur lequel il faut essayer toutes
les méthodes pour que ça s'arrange
un exemple pardon et veyran l'a dit
lui-même j'étais petit mon ancien métier
centres d'appels et je l'entends l'autre
jour je pense à la situation aujourd'hui
où on peut avoir personne au téléphone
ni à l'hôtel dieu qui fait des va nulle
part et veyran à d'une petite phrase
dans son discours il a dit je voudrais
mettre un centre d'appel ou une plate
forme privée je peux pas faire appel au
privé c'est à dire qu' il ya des
commissions il faut un appel d'offres
l'appel d'offres mais je rêve
avec trois mois parce qu'un appel
d'offres ces trois mois et il n'a pas pu
le faire j'ai retenu ça évidemment parce
que ça me concerne et ça passait comme
ça ça veut dire que il ya le sp2c qui
d'ailleurs le syndicat de six centres
d'appels avec des boîtes remarquablement
performante qui pourrait gérer cet
afflux d'appels
je ne sais pas comment ça a été géré
mais typiquement voilà pourquoi est-ce
que c'est l'administration qui gère ça
alors on pourra continuer de façon le
débat mais on l'a on l'a ouvert encore
réouvert ce soir je vous propose de
laisser la parole à nos internautes
avant de passer au deuxième thème tout
le monde ne le fait pas le
couvre feu de 18h par exemple la suisse
elle ferme les restaurants certains
commerces et normalement les écoles
c'est ce que me dit cet internaute
chardon bleu sur figaro live il fallait
surtout contrôler nos frontières depuis
longtemps et exiger 7 jours de
confinement pour tous ceux qui
rentraient sur le territoire alors
réponse d'elsa les français ne sont pas
irresponsables et responsable après
l'annus horribilis on peut peut-être
laissé les soufflets avec un sprint
donc ça c'est pour l'apéro à 18h
pourquoi pas sur figaro live françois
répond également à sophie sur les stages
surtout arrêter les stages et la
précarisation des jeunes donnez leur des
emplois je demande que ça
la santé des neiges va droit à l'emploi
la santé des étudiants alors tous les
tous les jeunes et tous les parents de
jeunes à vous entendre la semaine en
hausse également la santé des étudiants
ne fait que décliner l'instauration d'un
nouveau confinement va finir par nous
achever c'est bien nous donner 150 euros
dead mais c'est pas ça qui va nous
remonter le moral témoigne alex sur
youtube et il y a donc la question qui
était posée sur le site du figaro qui
demandait si vous étiez favorable à
l'extension de d'un couvre feu
à 18h généralisé à l'ensemble du pays et
c'est non à 60% et c'est également la
même chose sur twitter en tous les cas
dans les même ordre de grandeur
je vous propose de passer au deuxième
thème qui saura inspirer nos débatteurs
c'est ce qui s'est passé au tour de
carrefour c'est la douche froide en tous
les cas pour l'en pour l'enseigné ses
principaux actionnaires surtout puisque
le géant français de la distribution
venait tout juste d'engager des
pourparlers en vue de se vendre au prix
fort au groupe canadien à couche tard et
là le ministre de l'économie a pris son
téléphone est opposé son veto on
l'écouté carrefour c'est un chaînon
essentiel dans la sécurité alimentaire
de des français dans la souveraineté
alimentaire lesquelles je suis
viscéralement attachés communiste de
l'économie et comme ancien ministre de
l'agriculture
l'idée que carrefour puisse être racheté
par un concurrent étranger
a priori je ne suis pas favorable à ces
à cette mesure sophie votre foi quand
même très étonnés d'abord ce qui m'amuse
c'est que les français et y compris
d'ailleurs en haut lieu n'ont eu de
cesse de critiquer la grande
distribution
dieu c'est la malheureuse caissières de
carrefour qui est exploité la grande
distribution qui a tué le petit commerce
et tout d'un coup ça devient le sauveur
de l'état français je comprends pas
bruno le maire et est plutôt libérale
ça m'inquiète parce que c'était d'abord
tout à fait amiable et ils avaient envie
de voir comment ils pouvaient être
complémentaires je ne vois pas une
seconde le canadien a tout d'un coup
virer tout le monde en france et arrêter
carrefour parce que ça marchait pour ça
qu'il veut s'associer parce que ça
marche on a quand même signé un accord
avec le canada qui est quand même abbaye
sur pardon le scrutin oui un accord avec
le canada bon ce serait la russie
la chine qui voudrait racheter carrefour
on pourrait éventuellement mais là c'est
un accord à l'amiable tout le monde
était d'accord avec le canada je
comprends pas ce qui a pris à bruno le
maire alors vous désirez viens de
l'expliquer sens je vois un ministre se
dire qu'on va protéger des intérêts
français face à un rachat étrangers a
priori je serais plutôt favorable
ceci dit je suis un peu perplexe comme
sophie alors peut-être pas pour les
mêmes raisons
je pense que ça s'inscrit dans le
supposé tournant souverainistes de
emmanuel macron et du gouvernement
depuis depuis le début de la crise du
coc vide ceci dit alors pourquoi bloquer
carrefour pourquoi bouquet carrefour
alors que un an plus tôt on a voulu
privatiser aéroports de paris carrefour
cède un groupe privé pourquoi on
bloquerait carrefour alors qu'on voulait
privatiser
aéroports de paris et que on s'apprête à
démanteler edf le gouvernement s'apprête
à démanteler complètement edf sous les
recommandations je dirais pas les
ordures les recommandations de l'union
européenne le service public
d'électricité en france va être
démantelée mais par contre on monte sur
ses grands forcément vendues à des
étrangers
oui mais alors ouvert à la concurrence
il y aura forcément des nouilles au
rapprochement des groupes étrangers
mais en tout cas on monte sur nos grands
chevaux sur la souveraineté alimentaire
soit un groupe privé qui en plus je
rajoute quand même mais c'est une
entreprise alors je suis d'accord sur le
fait que le gouvernement doit opérer un
contrôle strict sur sur les garanties
par exemple le fait qu'il ait pas de
casse sociale en cas de rachat par un
groupe canadien à mon avis est
nécessaire et c'est le nouveau décret
qui permet ça ouais ceci dit je vois
prendre j'ai l'impression que c'est plus
une posture politique que vraiment
quelque chose de justifier sur le fond
c'est pas quelque chose qui une mesure
qui est prise en vertu d'une autre
disposition législative qui est au sein
de la loi pas qui fait que la
distribution alimentaire est rentré
comme rentrer dans l'équipe comme ce
secteur stratégique et liste protégé ici
mais d'ailleurs on fait partie d'une
liste est intéressante parce que depuis
2005 il existe un décret qui permet au
gouvernement de s'opposer à un rachat
par un groupe étranger d'une entreprise
française est en fait ce décret n'a
jamais été utilisé d'ailleurs que
par exemple l'aéroport de toulouse a été
racheté par des chinois le gouvernement
n'a pas eu tout n'a pas eu tous
intervenus alors là ils envisageraient
de le faire ceci dit attention
bruno le maire a dit qu'il était par
principe plutôt opposés il n'a pas
encore actionner le décret on sait pas
vraiment ce qu'il est ce qu'il en est
pour l'instant à l'automne il a été
fermé pour l'instant et ouais alors
peut-être que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec bruno le maire en tous les cas que
vous avez des doutes sur la sincérité de
bruno le maire
peut-être vous ayez entre les cas vous
êtes d'accord avec bruno retailleau en
tous les cas j'aimerais bien avoir
sophie et adrien votre réaction pure
carrefour il ya des concurrents
la casse sociale c'est un vrai problème
est là on doit être si l'acquisition
proposée par le canadien abouti à une
casse sociale il faut refuser bien sûr
y'a pas de soucis mais je veux une
cohérence voilà la souveraineté
alimentaire ça doit être pour l'ensemble
des activités économiques
alors il fait quand même un peu l'album
la fine bouche bruno retailleau il
devrait quand même être content non il
est comme vous levez pas il n'est pas
sûr de la sincère possible
pourquoi nous sommes six ans contre
toutes les décisions que prend le parti
opposé à cesser de l'opposition pure
selon vous il a comme une argumentation
oui et d'ailleurs j'ai été content de
voir que bono retailleau qui est quand
même quelqu'un de plutôt libéral a
souligné à juste titre j'aurais dû lui
dire tout à l'heure que quand on défend
la souveraineté alimentaire on ne signe
pas des traités de libre-échange avec le
monde entier et notamment avec le canada
comme l'a fait la france
voilà donc honnêtement il ya quand même
un problème de cohérence donc là sur ce
coup là vous êtes d'accord il ya une
contradiction entre le discours que
tient actuellement
bruno le maire et le fait d'avoir signé
le sexe en compte et que la sécurité le
tonneau mais alimentaire va qui peut
penser que que ça enlève quelque chose à
la france il ya un accord à l'amiable
passé avec un groupe canadien jeudi
c'est très irréaliste sur l'eau des
grands si on a des garanties on a des
garanties mais ce que je crois pas c'est
qu'il a immédiatement pris la parole
publiquement et c est donc je peux pas
dire que je ne comprends pas moi bien
avoir la réaction de mathieu bock-côté
ouais je me demande si je peux peut-être
apporter un peu plus de deux polémiques
à notre débat je pense que c'est bientôt
fini
c'est le moment je pense que la question
vaudrait si on était persuadé que les
grands patrons du cac 40 avaient le
patriotisme chevillé au corps or ce
n'est pas du tout le cas
en quoi les français l'intérêt général
des français seraient mieux garantie si
carrefour était dans les mains d'un
homme comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
d'entrepreneurs français f
carrefour par exemple a forcé de
nombreux sous-traitants a délocalisé au
début des années 2000 pour faire baisser
les prix
carrefour c'est une des entreprises les
plus inégalitaires de france c'est à
dire que alexandre bompard son patron
mais je vous pose la question sophie
dire comment justifier qu'alexandre
bompard gagnent entre 7 et u ils ont
d'euros par an alors qu'une caissière
gagne mais 400 euros par mois comme ça
c'est la question qu'on pose non-stop
alors je crois vraiment de réponse je
peux vous dire simplement que il a des
actionnaires qui votent ce salaire je
peux vous dire que les caissières bon
c'est certainement insuffisamment eu des
primes etc
parce qu'elles ont été pendant toute
cette période fidèle au poste courageuse
etc je peux vous dire que la seule
solution serait alors de mettre une
échelle dans les salaires et bien moi je
suis contre le fait de mettre une chaîne
dorée salaire pour une seule et bonne
raison d'ailleurs
à combien de fois le prix de la
caissière le pdg beau combien de fois la
caissière ben moi je sais pas s'il de 20
souvent évoqué c'est pas raisonnable non
plus et puis alors vous poser à notre
problème c'est que si je monte ma boîte
je veux gagner
tout l'argent que je veux et on n'a pas
le droit de me mettre une limite à mon
salaire si c'est moi qui risquait et qui
est créé ma boîte
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une prise de
risques parce qu'un entrepreneur c'est
quelqu'un qui plonge qui ne sait pas où
il va aller quand il crée sa boîte et je
pense que la prime de risque c'est la
scène de crise justifie gagner autant on
un jour que le salarié moyen en un mois
alors d'abord il gagne le tournage où je
parle de l'entrepreneur qui a monté sa
boîte il gagne autant on un jour je vais
vous dire au bout de 15 mais pas
maintenant pour le coup c'est un chiffre
de carrefour et à l'orgue à noter en un
jour que le salarié moyen guardian
beaucoup je suis un peu embêté de moi
j'ai une solution pour ça parce que je
déteste l'idée de mettre un multiple de
salaire moi je veux absolument et on
travaille là-dessus éthique je veux
absolument rendre les salariés
capitaliste je veux qu'il soit intéressé
je veux qu'ils puissent toucher les
dividendes de la participation est
beaucoup plus fortement et je pense que
au lieu de dire aux gens de leur donner
du temps du temps du temps et que et
parler sans arrêt des charges du travail
qu'il est je veux dire qu il qu'ils
soient sociales ces entreprises
intéressées passé et la participation ce
sera cet hommage au général de gaulle
que vous venez de rendre chercheurs
chine qui peut peut-être entrer
rencontré consensus on verra ça dans un
prochain débat entre les cas merci
beaucoup
en tous les cas de devoir débattue ce
soir
quelques petites annonces bon dans une
dernière
on saura si la paire ou pas à partir de
18 heures
en tous les cas sur les départements qui
ne sont pas concernés pour l'instant
s'il y en a déjà 25 qui sont sous
couvre-feu à partir de 18 heures
et puis demain à 11 heures franck
ferrand répondra à toutes vos questions
vous pouvez venir dialoguer avec lui
pendant une demi heure
ici sur le sur le site du figaro est
également sur youtube
donc j'attends vos questions c'est moi
qui les pousserait à franck ferrand qui
vient de
d'écrire un livre qui est paru à
l'automne mais qui est absolument très
très intéressant à lire un passionnant à
lire qui s'appelle autour d'eux
s'appelle jeanne d'arc un compte
politique
je le nom reviendra mais en tous les cas
je leur donnerai demain et le livre vaut
vraiment le coup
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis et
je vous dis donc à demain à 11 heures et
demain soir vous retrouvez guillaume
roquette même heure même endroit
[Musique]